uh what could it be welcome back could
it be that we have finally reached the
tipping point with wretched wokeness
this outrageous story you're about here
certainly makes a powerful case that we
are an assistant professor at old
dominion university in virginia
attempting to normalize yes normalized
pedophilia
advocating we
destigmatize and rebrand these deeply
sick members of society
i use the term minor attracted person or
math in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons
first of all because i think it's
important to use terminology for groups
that members of that group want others
to use for them
and math advocacy groups like before you
act
um have advocated for use of the term
map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender
and that isn't true and it leads to a
lot of misconceptions about attractions
toward minors how could a sex offender
not be a pedophile i just don't get that
the university thank god though coming
to its senses after that nonsense
placing that professor on leave and the
president of old dominion issuing this
statement i want to state in the
strongest terms possible that child sex
abuse is morally wrong
and has no place in our society
close call it sounds i know yeah
[Laughter]
the professor later saying i want to be
clear child sexual abuse is an
inexcusable crime okay now we're ready
and we're back and we're back
well uh i drew the line at chess feeders
and birthing people as not just for
women
this person goes by the pronouns they
them and is transgendered people who
warned about this language manipulation
and rejection of reality leading to
something like this redefining the terms
of child sex abuse and pedophilia were
called bigots and intolerant so i'm glad
that we have a line for this kind of
language manipulation but these are the
same people who have been saying that
you should allow people like this
professor of sociology and criminal
justice to put drag queens in your
kindergartner's school for
story hour so if you're a parent and
you're saying no thank you like my
underage kid is not going to be
subjected to this rejection of of
reality uh you're not a bigot you're
perfectly within your rights of of
thinking that i'm actually flashing back
to grade school in the city here and i
think there were drag queens
entertaining the children uh but uh
listen to this a minor attracted person
so you knew you know who not to hire for
your babysitter the minor attracted
person yeah i don't know geraldo i i see
this as like
i want to support full academic
scholarship you should be able to pursue
as far as you want any taboo or
controversial issue
but this is not a legitimate academic
pursuit this is trying to
have a phd
help with the branding for the pedophile
community that's what this is about and
it's taxpayer money this is funded by
the taxpayers at old dominion public
school
this kind of is like the illegal
immigration thing oh you can't call them
illegal immigrants
because illegal sticky stigmatizing them
and we don't want to do that so we're
just going to call them wanderers or
something like that you have stigmas for
a reason geraldo okay pedophilia has a
bad stigma because it's one of the
nastiest things you can do now here's
what she says she says that
just because you are attracted to a
minor doesn't mean those people act on
that attraction
okay
show me someone who's attracted to you
that person
show me someone that's attracted to a
young child as an adult that hasn't
tried to touch that person who hasn't um
surveilled a playground who hasn't put
themselves in an environment where other
children are around or maybe even
watched it on the internet
no
that attraction is the strongest
attraction in the human body it's
hormonal it's inside your body it's
chemical inside your body
nothing you can do about that you have
to keep those people away from children
and stop trying to soft pedal it like
it's just some attraction no one pursues
but is this dana
you know so stupid
that it it it will
affect
is it isn't wokeness in retreat
isn't this like the last gasp this is so
ridiculous such a stupid idea i guess i
mean they keep giving us examples to
bring up i mean they're they're not
stopping i do think that the american
people are saying like we are sick of it
but i i see his point that her point
sorry is it i don't know they them that
they say they their point did i
misgender her or him i think so
i apologize go to hr right now
with the point being
that perhaps somebody is attracted to
children but they haven't acted on it
but i do think that there's a this this
has missed a point all day long which is
the outrageousness of child pornography
and the pervasiveness of that all around
the world on the internet is
so disgusting and it's happening all
across the world and if you think about
one of the things that the justice
department recently did they had that
big takedown of that child pornography
syndicate i mean there is harm that can
be done to children even if they're not
touched by the person who has that
attraction that that is a huge issue
the justice department just did that
recently yeah well done garland stick to
that stuff
stick to that garland
so
too far a bridge too far
does it close
does it cause
i'm going to come out against pedophilia
all right
on the woke side no no but of course of
course of course but the thing is
everybody makes fun of people
who
warn that this will be happening and
then when it happens nobody remembers
the warning we have been in this process
process of shifting condemnation from
the deranged to those who who wish to
not comply to the demands of the
deranged uh there are stories in which
lesbian women are called transphobic
bigots because they won't have sex with
trans women who have intact male
genitalia that is not for me that is
from the guardian a very left-wing paper
out of england we are at a point where
you wait
for example i mean if like let's say if
you don't want a lap dancing uh drag
queen in your kindergarten that's on you
now that's way different than what we're
talking about but it's like all of a
sudden you're the uptight parent or
you're the lesbian who is a bigot
because you won't sleep with a trans
female who has male genitalia the point
of being a lesbian is that that's not
her thing
okay she doesn't want to see that stuff
in her bedroom so why are you coming in
there and demanding it nobody wants it
why are you so emotionally engaged
because this is such a great story and
also because jesse took my talking point
which is stigmatization exists for a
reason but you know it's weird in a back
out in a back end way you almost agreed
with the professor by saying it's
biological and if it is biological it is
not free will so that means the
pedophile has no choice in what their
thoughts but that does not stop that
does not stop you from stopping them
from having access to children that's
true whatever their motivation is
whether it's sincere or not i don't give
away i don't think they're born
pedophiles i think something happens to
them usually in their childhood usually
they're molested as children
and then
it could be usually that's what happens
and they do that to other children did
you cut the coupon out in the comic to
get my talking points on psychiatry hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else